peu
[Applaudissements]
c'est drôle ce qui n'est drôle à
regarder
et là tu attends tu fais la tête moi
j'ai envie de rigoler c'est l'alcool qui
monte en maths est doux l'alcool que
j'ai pris ce soir afin d'y puiser le
courage de t'avouer que j'en ai marre de
toi et de tes commérages de ton corps
qui me laisse sage et qui m'enlève tout
et soir
j'en ai assez faut bien que je te le dis
du m'exaspère d'une tyrannie
je subis ton sale caractère san jose
vais te dire que tu exagères ouais tu
exagères tu le sais maintenant
parfois je voudrais étrangler dieu que
tu as changé en cinq ans tu te laisses
aller tu te laisses elle est battue est
belle à regarder des bâtiments sur tes
chaussures et ton vieux peignoir mal
fermées et des bigoudis qu'elle a lu je
me demande chaque jour
comment as tu fait pour me plaire
comment ai-je pu de faire la cour est
aliéné ma vie entière comme ça tu
ressembles à ta mère
car rien pour inspirer l'amour
devant mes amis quelle catastrophe tu me
contredis du m'apostrophe avec ton venin
et hargne tu ferais pas trop des
montagnards j'ai décroché le gros lot le
jour où je t'ai rencontrée si tu te
faisais ce serait trop beau non tu te
laisses aller tu te laisses aller tuer
une brute est un tyran tu n'as pas de
coeur et padam important autant je pense
bien souvent que malgré tout tu es ma
femme si tu voulais faire un effort tout
pourrait reprendre sa place qu'on
maigrir fait un peu de sport arrange toi
devant la glace accroche un sourire à
tafas maggie ton coeur et au corps
au lieu de penser que je te déteste et
de me fuit comme la peste essaie de te
montrer gentil redevient la petite fille
qui m'a donné tant de bonheur est
parfois comme par le passé
j'aimerais que tous contre mon coeur tu
te laisses aller
utley l est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]